one of our senior instructors big data
and data engineering and we're here to
talk with you this evening about the
University of California Irvine
data engineering boot camp program that
simply learned delivers for the
University
and
it's a
intensive online program that will get
you into Data engineering
fairly quickly so we'll talk about data
engineering as a career field
we'll also talk about what this program
offers you how the program gets your job
ready the curriculum and the learning
management system
we'll talk about enrollment steps and
then we'll take your questions please
put those into the the chat or
preferably the Q a function in WebEx
that way we'll be able to keep track of
those
and we'll take those during the Q a
toward the end of this session
um so to introduce Greg
um he is a noted expert in Big Data data
science AI cloud computing 30 odd years
in the business if I have that correct
Greg
yeah I'd like to update that nobody
knows what network even is anymore
exactly
but uh but yeah um so he brings to his
instruction not only technical knowledge
but a vast
background and Industry experience and
how things work in the real world
that's one of the great things about the
programs that simply learn uh offers in
conjunction with the UCI is that we
bring both UCI instructors as well as
industry professionals to teach these
courses so
we'll talk a little bit about the the
area of big data and data engineering um
we live in a world that's
basically drowning Us in data
it's it's gotten
more intensive last couple of years
during the pandemic because
companies that thought of themselves as
brick and mortar institutions
I've had to move to non-contact for a
period of time they've all moved to
remote work for a period of time
um
all of these types of interactions that
we used to do face to face became
digital and they became digital they
became data sources every touch point a
source of more data about
the behavior of customers suppliers
systems in the real world Internet of
Things
and
the the amount of data that
organizations have to deal with in order
to do their work in order to understand
where their future is and how to prepare
for it
just mushrooming
this is why
the term Big Data came about and this is
why data Engineers are so critical
to
organizations today
the people who build and maintain the
data structures the architectures for
data
systems for ingesting and conditioning
the data so that it can be used in large
applications and especially in
artificial intelligence machine learning
dance analytics these are all
very important areas that have to exist
without dating engineer
never done a simple thing like
taking information about a meeting and
its participants and trying to put that
into an Excel spreadsheet
in a way where all the data is uniformly
coded
um
that can take you
anywhere from half an hour to many hours
depending on the number of lines in that
spreadsheet and that's a manual data
Engineering Process and a very small
database but when you start talking
about
the types of commercial and Industrial
scale systems
the world depends on now
it has to be an automated process and it
has to to be done
with a solid engineering foundation so
um Greg what are we what are you seeing
out in the in the world
as far as Trends and data engineers and
Big Data
yeah and some of you guys can maybe
start taking little notes about things
that we say that are interesting to you
because really big data started off as
being a fairly big thing when they
invented it you know several years ago
and then it evolved into something uh
quite uh difficult for businesses to get
their hands wrapped around but they knew
they needed to do it and and now it's
become it's become more mainstream
there's a lot more places that you can
exercise your skills in understanding
data engineering understanding how to
manipulate uh data so there's a lot of
corollary skills which you'll want to
pick up along the way make sure you know
how to use some of the major databases
out there like those
hello SQL servers and stuff like that
but also be aware that the whole
methodology
these huge big data sets and making them
available to members of either your
company or your customers a lot of those
things are evolving quite rapidly to
make it simpler to to increase the level
of abstraction between you the developer
or you the analyst and the end user so
there's a lot exciting thing is there's
a lot going on that's the exciting thing
it's kind of figuring out where do I
start and where do I want to end up
that's that's that's kind of where the
where you're going to want to kind of
focus a little bit
yeah I mean to that point
from a good foundation you can go in a
number of different
directions in this field and
these job roles emphasize data
engineering but
um you can also move peripherally into
other data related roles AI roles that
type of thing so
there's a number of different paths that
you can take
in your career when you as Greg just
said yeah look at where you want to
start and where you want to end up yeah
I would say the biggest one you got
there is probably data engineer the the
which basically means you understand a
lot about various types of data how to
normalize how to load it how to cleanse
it things like that then the rest of
those jobs are typically going to be a
little bit more specialized when you
figure out what you're good at what your
company needs so the the big mountain to
get around is large amounts of data and
fortunately this course has got several
examples of acquiring and pulling in
data and starting to do basic
manipulation on them so those are some
of the yeah and then Cloud doesn't say
cloud up there but cloud is also pretty
hot
yeah yeah
and as I mentioned you have to have the
foundation so you've got to understand
real-time processing pipelining
how to
duct transform the data into
structured and unstructured databases uh
data Lakes
data warehouses
um
how to protect it maybe to encrypt it
um the tools you're going to need for
analyzing it and visualizing it so that
you understand how it's going to be used
by the end users or the people who take
that data from you and run it through
their their systems to provide actual
intelligence and actionable insights to
Executives and
data governance and clients control
extremely important and as that's an
area that you emphasize a lot great
absolutely
so yeah the government governance I'm
glad you mentioned that governance is uh
honestly I mean in my opinion it's
boring but but I will tell you what it's
so important so when you find things
that are quote unquote boring sometimes
those are the ones to dig into because
that's you know the management folks
they like people who are all about
making sure that the the data is being
massaged properly it's being tracked
properly all the government requirements
are being executed properly that the
world of data is is really huge and big
data is honestly a small piece of data
engineering so they kind of keep that in
mind too it's there's a lot to it but
it's also a small piece of the overall
data environment so lots of opportunity
is the good thing that's the important
thing yeah and it's kind of a testament
to how how life has changed over the
last
decade or so
um
to think that
uh what we used to think of as private
information about ourselves was what our
social security numbers were or what's
on our birth certificate and now
um there's so many more different types
of things that we declare as personal
data and we would not want fared Within
uh yeah pii is the real common term for
that person exactly yeah yeah that's a
good point yeah we didn't mention we
didn't mention but data security I
didn't say it specifically and it wasn't
in that job list but data security for a
lot of businesses the top tier so once
you really understand data you want to
make sure you understand how you're
securing it preventing others from
getting access to it
so we have a question for you in the
audience I'm going to bring this up for
you
WebEx tool if you happen to be watching
on a streaming service you can put your
answers into the comments
but if you're on WebEx you can answer
this directly in the widget that's just
popped up on your screen
and we'll give you just about 30 seconds
to deal with that so basically you know
what has prevented you from enrolling in
a program like this or moving into this
area
the date if you haven't done that yet
why not
um
and we're curious to know
another about 15 seconds to go
we'll close the poll in three
two
one
here is the result
so the most common answer uh
three-fifths of the audience say that
you know you don't you haven't found a
program that feel comfortable or
confident at the end of saying yes I can
show you that I have done this type of
work I am
qualified as a data engineer because
here's the work I've done
it gives you something that gives you a
practical experience to say that with
confidence
um and the other two major reasons you
can see here
not finding a comprehensive curriculum
that covers all of the skills that we
talked about but also having difficulty
to fit this into your your work schedule
so what we'll talk about now is this
particular program which is
the data engineering boot camp
it is offered by the University of
California Irvine
their division of continuing education
and it's delivered by simply learn the
completely online program
and it has comprehensive curriculum that
UCI has worked with industry
for what they need and aligning it to
types of
people that they want delivered out of
their training programs
integrated case studies Hands-On
projects
things that give you that practical
experience using the tools and the
platforms that you would be using in
your actual work as a data engineer
and combined with online virtual
classrooms where you interact live with
your instructors every week
um good their instructional material but
you also get to ask them the questions
that keep you on track in your course
you get to interact with your peers
through the platform
and
between live classes you have a 24 7
access to the learning platform that
allows you to get to
um
any work that you need to do but also
ask questions from support staff
included questions out on the here
community board and that type of thing
and about a six
month program we say that it's about 10
hours a week outside of the classroom
hour requirement
yeah so it is some a commitment of time
and effort
but it's something that will get you to
some great results so
you earn a certificate from the
University of California
you see Irvine that attests to your
completion of the material that you
successfully mastered
material in all the courses in the
curriculum you'll also along the way
pick up a
IBM issued certificate or two from some
of the classes that they offer
and you'll get multiple projects that
give you the hands-on experience
including a final project Capstone
project
which allows you to demonstrate that
you've mastered all of the skills in the
program
it pulls together
by giving you an industry-based
challenge problem to solve it pulls
together all of the different tools and
techniques and skills that you've
learned
so that you can demonstrate those in
that Capstone project we'll talk a
little bit more about that you get
master classes from UCI instructors and
from IBM industry instructors if you are
in a field that requires continuing
education education units if your
employer or your licensing body requires
it you can earn up to 15 CES through
this program and we'll also offer you
career assistance for those of you who
are looking not just to apply this in
your current job but to use this as a
springboard the bigger and better things
in your career
so let's talk a little bit about the
University of California Irvine it is
uh one of the newer campuses in the UC
system the UC system being
um
most of you should know the
uh Flagship public education institution
uh in
the United States
one of the top public education
institutions in the world and UC Irvine
is a top campus in the system especially
for technology especially emphasizes
Applied Technologies and it's generated
Nobel Prize winners
not as many as my alma mater UC Berkeley
but
I had to I had to throw that in there
but yeah
but um
definitely a fine institution that is
well recognized worldwide so the the
certificate you earned from UC Irvine
having that on your
curriculum your TV or your your resume
is going to be something that will help
you get placed
um
IBM
also participates directly in this
program
they offer not only the course and big
data for data engineering but they also
offer hackathons ask me anything
sessions you can interact with their
staff members
see master classes which are taught by
IBM industry experts
so all of that is an additional value
and make sure that this program is
aligned to Industry best practices and
what industry requires
that's a really a valuable aspect of
kind of program
the last thing I'll mention about the
benefits the program
is simply learned career assist service
so for us Learners this is a U.S
oriented program we have other programs
oriented towards Learners All Around the
World in all different countries but
this uh UCI boot camp is specifically
for use U.S Learners and it includes
several things that will help you
develop your career
we'll talk about expert webinars and
career events we'll talk about the
projects that build up your portfolio
that you can demonstrate your experience
and skills
but we'll start off by talking about Job
assist services that we offer in
conjunction with Talent Inc and talent
Inc offers are the program participants
several
aspects this goes through your first six
months as you're taking the program it
continues for six months afterwards uh
you not only get access to a job portal
specific job board oriented towards
people taking this course
um
you also get to other very important
Services one is resume review rewrite
Service uh being able to to revamp your
resume
so that it um
not only looks good when it gets to a
person's desk but it survives the
process that
acts as the gatekeeper between you and
that person namely the automated
AI
processes that's pre-screen resumes
every company uses them
resumes get free screened through AI
algorithms
understanding how to structure your
resume and what content needs to be
there in order to pass that screening is
a vital skill
help you with that and then we also make
sure that the resume looks good when it
does get through that process and goes
to human beings who will look at it and
evaluate you and ask you in for
interviews
interview process
extremely important because as anyone
who's ever had a job knows you have to
go through multiple layers of interview
technology
the first layers being evaluation of
your skills and your hard skills and
Technology
and then use for your soft skills
or even player qualities
and your fit with management and culture
all of those things we help you with
because you get one-on-one interviewing
practice sessions you get career
coaching sessions and get the
opportunity to improve and show your
best foot forward in
personal interactions you're going to
have so these aspects of the program
also are extremely valuable
whether you're going to switch employers
whether you're going to try to move up
current employer you are going to have
to go through that interviewing process
so that's a really important thing it's
definitely learn itself conducts a
number of ongoing webinars in technology
in career management
these are all things that are available
to you for free
webinars multiple times a week on
various topics some of them are like
this one which is a description of one
of our programs but many of them are as
you see here
friends in the industry in particular
areas
how to manage your career how to get the
most out of a job search those types of
things so these are all things that are
extremely useful to you in ongoing
education and career development then we
talk about the industry aligned projects
so here's a sampling of some of the
projects that you would encounter in the
UCI data engineering boot camp
social media able to
create the
system for ongoing
monitoring of sentiment on the social
media platform like meta or Facebook
online streaming management Employment
Services all of these as you can see are
oriented towards
real world problems in Industry case
study type problems where you'd be offer
The Challenge and you'll be shown how to
apply the technicals and techniques
build your own solution for each of
these
so
that
description of what you get out of the
project or the program
what you need to get into the program
uh do you need a bachelor's degree in a
relevant discipline so it should be in a
technology discipline computer science
engineering that type of thing
with the GPA of 2.0 or above
you do need to have some basic
understanding of object oriented
programming you don't have to be a
programmer but you do have to understand
some of the principles
and we don't require but we recommend
that you have two or more years of work
experience uh necessarily in the data
engineering field but just to do it for
more years of work experience so that
you understand what are the requirements
of an employee in an organization
so with that I'm going to ask you one
more question which is
how much of a how much experience do you
have workplace
got a gauge for who's in the audience
tonight
oops
let me open question here
I'll give you just about 20 seconds for
that
I always find it interesting to watch as
I get to see in real time the answer is
coming in so
as the bars shift
and here is the result
so we have a relatively even
distribution but the interesting thing
is about a third of folks have less than
two years of experience barely knew in
the
workplace but another third have more
than 10 years
I presume you are folks who are looking
at possibly pivoting from the area
you're in into Data engineering so
we'll talk about how this applies to
both the groups
and
so this is the point of the program
where I'm going to stop sharing the
slides and allow Greg to take over the
screen
and he'll talk about these various
things
actual learning environment itself
okay
now I don't have a screen to show right
okay so I'll let you talk verbally if
you would like me to put the slide back
up I can do that yeah yeah leave that
slide up so I'm while I'm chatting so
that way I'll just hit the major topics
uh based on what's what yeah what what
Stewart said was that a couple things
are actually very very important the uh
the skill set that you guys have the
third lesson two the third over ten uh
maybe in the Q a section maybe put in
maybe what some of your goals are that
would be helpful for us to see that
because obviously someone that's only
got less than two years gonna have a
different goal and someone's been doing
this for 10 years and um I would imagine
a difference and the same thing for the
guys in the middle there are two to five
and six to ten don't want to leave you
guys out either so one of the things
that we're going to to be able to do
with you on a regular basis is let you
see the curriculum from end to end right
off the bat so the first thing you'll
see in the Big Data program is you'll
see the entire curriculum all of all the
topics uh which things are going to be
live what where the labs fall uh you can
ask questions about how we're going to
do the Labs what's expected of us that
sort of thing that's your curriculum the
other thing for the classes that I teach
I usually usually early in the program I
will share ancillary pieces that I know
are directly related to that particular
topic so that if you happen to have some
extra downtime and you want to continue
moving forward you can focus on specific
things that you might want to emphasize
about yourself so your your curriculum
starts off with the course itself the
course materials uh the the live virtual
classroom is being referred to here is
is basically where you've got content
educational content online that you can
look at both in the class and when the
class is not running so it's available
anytime and then the other piece of that
is the the labs now the labs are
interesting because the labs are aimed
at the particular course but I can tell
you like in the Big Data program
specifically there's some other skills
that are super important to really have
a base understanding of like programming
for example if you're not a programmer
and you're in a big data course you're
going to want to know a little bit about
basic programming skills probably python
python is one of the most common
languages in the Big Data world that
will take you uh through quite a few
different exercises without learning yet
another language there's quite a few
languages so you want to get your hands
around at least one that you can get a
lot of support from lots of groups lots
of Community Support so that would be
one thing the other area you see on that
list there is uh there's interactive
tests that the instructor normally gives
those so the the tests are part of the
curriculum and you come up to the end of
the course and you get to go through the
testing and then you you bring your
answer and then you can discuss any any
topic or related topic that is that
might be a concern to you the uh the the
big thing to do is some of the stuff
that Stuart was asking you for here and
I've asked you for is kind of what your
goals are because what normally happens
when I'm teaching I find there's a lot
of commonality with the with the people
and there's also a lot of oh do I have
the right experience I'm gonna I want to
add something regarding experience real
quickly here
um you take your your experience can
come from many different places what I
used to do live seminars to help people
get indoctrinated into a
technology-based career we would go
through and find out what what have you
done before have you done marketing
before have you done sales have you been
have you done training have you done
mentoring what have you done in the past
that could be reapplied to this career
field and of course there's almost
almost anything you've done prior except
maybe waiting tables
um Can can be reapplied in a lot of
cases to a job seeking so I always
encourage people to don't poo poo
anything you've done is not being
relevant or not being right make a list
of what those things are and see which
things you can use to bend to your your
new career field so that would lead us
let me go to the next piece there the
Capstone project so when you get to a
project like the other thing that you
want to be reasonably aware of is how
does a project work so if you have never
done or managed a project before there's
plenty of really cool tools out on that
web not typically part of a course like
this one but I always suggest to the
folks that are taking my classes that
here's some free project management
tools that will help you map out what
you're doing when you need to get things
done and that skill in and of itself is
enough to get you a pretty good position
at a lot of companies if you've got the
other relevant technical skills because
a lot of times they need people who can
take a complex situation break it down
put parameters around it activities to
do and then make it all happen cult
project management program management
business analysts there's lots of
different titles and the skill set
varies across the board that's kind of
why you want to know about these things
because you might not get the first job
as you're going through all these
different environments that you really
want you might have to do a couple of
Stepping Stones to get there and be
understanding the whole nature of
defining and executing a project is
important for almost anybody so that
would be something to do during that
Capstone project and then once you've
got your projects running then you're
going to be able to unlock certificates
and get some additional support tools
but you all have been around long enough
to know that the internet has got a
wealth of information on it so as you're
going through the program and going
through the course and you realize oh
we're not going to go to Advanced python
no not in a big data course or not but
can you go and advanced python yes you
can and if you've got an aptitude for
something
that still has been marked down for
yourself by the way whatever you guys
think you have an aptitude for bullet
that out somewhere and maybe focus on
that first because that'll be easier for
you because you've got an aptitude for
it already so as you go through this
course as you're going through materials
listening to your instructor kind of
keep some of these things in mind
because at the end of the day the whole
the whole ability to act to move
yourself forward respect firmly on your
shoulders nobody can open up your brain
do like one of those Matrix things and
plug in and you're jacked in and now you
know Kung Fu not happening so anyway
I'll throw it back to you Stuart thank
you I appreciate that Greg and Craig
talk about the the system tracks your
your
curriculum that tracks your progress to
the curriculum Greg correctly pointed
out you've got to be responsible for
your progress the system will give you
some
particulars and reminders show you your
calendar of upcoming classes and that
type of thing but it's up to you to
put in the effort to show up to the
classes
put in the work between classes that
type of thing so
um
we we mentioned that because this is
very rigorous in
intensive program six months is not a
lot of time to learn all these things
take all of these core classes you start
off with the orientation which is very
straightforward just gives you an idea
of what the learning management system
looks like and what you expected of you
um then you move into the Big Data
Hadoop and Spark
um
basic information then you go into Cloud
AWS
um how to manage big data on AWS
um we've moved you also to Azure so you
can see the second of the major Cloud
platforms and data engineering on azure
and that moves you to the data engine
Capstone project so along the way you're
going to pick up all the various aspects
and skills that we've described you also
have the ability to take electives which
are included in the price of the boot
camp
but you can take based on your
availability your interest and your
level of
commitment
take big data for data engineering
that's that IBM course you can take the
academic master classes by UCI and the
industry master classes from IBM and
then you can also learn about Google
Cloud platform fundamentals so that you
have that third platform to the
to the mix uh
with that kind of foundation of AWS
Azure and PCP then
probably be able to
adapt your skills into any type of cloud
platform that you might encounter but
there really aren't that many others so
um you will use a number of different
tools
uh
thing about that is
this isn't just a matter of you'll be
able to put these on your resume as
buzzwords you'll be able to put them on
your resume as I have done projects with
each of these tools and so I know how to
use them and I can show you
fact examples of how I have used them so
this is a really great way to build up
your muscles in this area
and as as it notes at the bottom there's
a number of other tools and platforms
Frameworks that you're going to be
learning so
uh we're very proud that we can
give you this kind of a
Foundation
and when you take that Foundation
you take a challenge project and you do
your Capstone project
um
based on that challenge problem
this will occupy the last several weeks
of your of your six-month course
this will all involve you working under
the mentorship of an instructor like
Greg who will meet with you weekly
to help you stay on course not get stuck
down dead ends or blocks but continue to
work on solving that
uh challenge problem industry aligned
real world type problem and build your
solution to it so your successful
completion of the Capstone project is
the basically the final exam of the
course
shows that you have successfully
completed a curriculum mastered the
skills
and it's something that goes into your
git portfolio so that you're able to
then share that
as an example demonstrate
what you have done
so this is
put a lot of emphasis on this because it
is very important
so Julie pie is the listen assistant
director of the
technology programs and continuing
education
division at the Irvine and
she
helps design the curriculum and how it's
delivered so Jesus the overall director
and Mentor for the the program
makes sure that this is the program that
University of California
stands behind puts its resources behind
and is proud of
uh just a little bit of a note about who
are the ideal ideal candidates to go
into this program or want to go into
this program uh it professionals
beginners and data science uh data
science professionals who want to move
into their skill set people in other
fields who want to Pivot into Big Data
people with programming skills
people with
business intelligence and analytics
skills so it's
basically anybody who counters or uses
data or wants to be able to use data to
solve problems
this is a good foundational course for
you
but with all of that said
giving you a
fairly good overview of the program
just want to take a quick
monitor of who might be interested in
the program
I'll just give you another 15 20 seconds
to that
okay
just a few more seconds we'll close the
pool
okay and the poll result
so about eighty percent of the folks who
responded said that they're interested
in enrolling in the program which is
great
what we'll do now
is share with you how to do that
so it's very straightforward
you'll want to con contact us through
the email at ask us simplylearn.net
and that will put you in touch with our
learning counselors and admissions
counselors who will help you I'm going
to put into the chat right now
both of that email address as well as
the
URL of the program
page so you can see more information
about the program itself
so that's in the chat for you
and
so once you submit the application we'll
review your qualifications make sure
that they meet the prerequisite
requirements
may do an evaluation test to show to see
how you will do on object oriented
programming Concepts and you'll get an
admission offer by email
um the fees for this program flat U.S
eight thousand dollars
um can be financed at 704 dollars a
month interest refinancing
and you'll want to contact us ask us at
simplylearn.net to find out when the
next cohort starts
you'll be starting within the next month
or two
um so
with that said I think we can move on
two questions and answers so I'm gonna
stop sharing the screen so we don't
stare at Slide the whole time
I want to bring up
a couple of questions from the audience
so far
um and I invite you to
if you're watching to go in and put your
questions into the Q a or the chat right
now
but Lamont has a question
but in the event an employer pays for
the boot camp through grant funding how
does the tuition payment get handled so
Lamonte with tuition reimbursement
um that's a policy that your employer
will set so some employers will in fact
pay the tuition directly
and we can bill to them
um
some employers require that you pay for
the course and they will reimburse you
directly once you complete it
successfully but again you need to check
with your HR and your Learning and
Development Department at your employer
to determine uh if they have tuition
reinforce reimbursement and how they
administer it
that's that question
um
which days of the week and what times
are live classes held in the Pacific
time zone
and in if that live classes conflict
with the work schedule are the sessions
recorded or the material can be reviewed
we got a little Lamont for that question
um Greg these are usually morning
classes for the people in the Pacific
zone right yeah yeah the ones that I've
been doing have usually started at like
at 10 o'clock in the morning with wait
wait wait I'm on the East Coast so
um whatever that is on the west coast I
guess that's pretty early right yeah but
those these are four hour classes on
Saturdays and Sundays
um
because this is a UCI boot camp and it's
oriented toward the
folks who live in on the west coast
um believe the class time start a little
bit later Saturdays and Sundays and at 7
A.M but again it's usually a morning
start
again seven again Saturday and Sunday
you do have to show up to a certain
number of the actual classes throughout
the course curriculum in order to meet
the attendance requirement but as you
ask yes the the classes are recorded So
if there's a kind of a conflict on a
given weekend if there's something
having to do with work or having to do
with their personal life that requires
you not to attend the class that weekend
you will be able to review the
recordings before the
next class the polling again
so that's important to note that should
go into this
with the intention of showing up to
the the
bulk of the actual live classes
here's a good question for you Greg
because you would know this better than
I how approximately how many students
are in each cohort
um yeah it kind of varies if there's not
enough then we don't run the class I'll
just be honest with you guys so the the
club is smallest class I've had was
maybe 12 and then I think the biggest
class I've ever had was probably 30 but
it was more of a conceptual there wasn't
as much requirement to interact back and
forth it was more of a lecture based but
I would say between 12 and 20 is
probably about average yeah
um
is there any form of sponsorship for
simple learn for this course uh
Benson no we we don't offer sponsorship
scholarships bursaries any of that type
of thing we do offer the no finance and
no interest financing so that's how we
try to help people afford the course
fit it into their budget
and upon program completion does a
student get a physical certificate from
UCI
is the certificate mailed to the student
the answer to that is yes upon request
you will receive a physical certificate
some people
don't need that don't want that they
simply take the the digital version and
use that
image in their LinkedIn profile or have
that available but upon request you
can't receive an actual physical
suitable for framing certificate from
UCI the
because we UCI knows that that's an
important
um to some for some folks to be able to
to show that off both
personally in their office or home
environment but also to show it off to
uh
cures and employers who might be
interested in having that
um
Lamont asks a great question and this is
a question I have to direct you to the
folks that ask us at simplylearn.net
question is is the program of va
approved boot camp where the GDI bill
can be used post 911 via bill
um
so I don't personally know the answer to
that
one thing I do know is that as an
organization simply learned has worked
with Veterans Administration and
Veterans other organizations on Skilling
programs but I cannot speak to a
specific connection between this program
and any ba approved funding
um
and divine asks if we have a cloud
computing course there are cloud
computing courses that we offer as you
as you saw in the curriculum divine much
of this course uh goes into the cloud
environment the cloud platforms and how
to use
those
in processing or setting up the Big Data
environment
um
another good question what are the
hardware and software requirements for
this boot camp you need a laptop or
desktop computer with web browser
um
that's
relatively as far as the requirements go
because everything will be done through
an online
software as a service
learning management system
so you don't have to in general have
software that runs on your own system or
have requirements of that nature you
will be able to access much of the
self-paced video content on other
devices like your phone or tablet but we
recommend that you have a desktop or
laptop in order to be able to do the
actual Project work simply because it's
really hard to do that on a tiny screen
the touchscreen keyboard
um
do you have any other comments on that
Greg
um yeah I would say that realistically
you should probably put into your list
of things to get at some point if you
don't already have a laptop you're
probably going to want to get one
because a lot of the a lot of the things
you're going to want to do will be tools
that you're going to want to download
and use try out become familiar with if
you're in an interview process and you
don't know how to use Jupiter notebook
for example uh that's not necessarily
going to be good for a big data
environment so you might want to have
some ability to do your own as I said
you can you can go online and use the
LMS ones but realistically if you're
going to really get into it
out in the future try to get your hands
on a PC or a Mac so um but it doesn't
have to be a big powerful gaming machine
unless that you just like gaming
machines just a real basic even you know
even a used one is fine there's plenty
of them out there that are pretty budget
oriented but
um yeah I would I would not want to go
to an interview and not know how to use
the basic
facility of a laptop the first thing
that gives you in a new job usually is a
new laptop so right that's why you don't
have to necessarily buy one because
every time I've gone in somewhere to do
a project they have your laptop like
immediately because I'm not allowed to
use mine no no no not the secure
corporate environment they'll usually
get they'll usually give you one
that's one of the funny things about
the pandemic is uh
somebody mentioned early on if they had
told an executive who said if they had
told us that we needed to move everyone
to work from home we would have said it
will take six months and 10 million
dollars a budget
when it happened it took three days with
no budget uh yeah but the flip side of
that is a lot of people are working on
their personal computers they're
personally on property rather than
corporate owned systems so
um
we we envision that that's going to
swing back to corporate on because again
as Greg said uh especially if you're
dealing with sensitive data uh security
oh yeah having that computer being owned
company owned property within the
perimeter of its security
management system is very important yeah
uh I don't see any other questions that
have come in
so with that I'm going to
move to the last
question that I'm going to ask the
audience
it's pretty straightforward
but
for the folks who have said
that they're interested
in this program
when would you like to start and let's
start this
last poll question here
and again about 20 seconds I know that's
about 15 seconds too long but
just want to make sure everybody gets a
chance to answer
and we'll close the poll in about five
seconds more
that would be three
two
one
so here's the
result
we always like to say if this is
something that's going to change your
life and your career for the better it's
always worth thinking about doing it
sooner than later about half of you
agree with that so
um something that immediately another
quarter within three months and
um again this program will be available
for the foreseeable future so if
you want to
take more time to plan it out it'll be
available but again we'd love to welcome
you in to our next upcoming cohort
to find out about that I would suggest
that you
oops sorry contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
speak to our learning consultants for
that and find out
specifics about course requirements
cohort dates and that type of thing and
and we look forward to welcoming you
into the UCI Learning Community
um hope to see you there and thank you
Greg for sharing your knowledge and
insights with everyone here tonight
yeah no problem thank you for inviting
me
and um thank you to everyone who joined
us this evening have a great great a
great rest of the evening
and uh we'll see you soon